nos dicen qué problemas se puede
resolver con 42 entre 7 y nos dan tres
diferentes escenarios por aquí para
elegir uno de ellos así que pausa el
vídeo y dale un vistazo antes de que lo
trabajemos juntos
muy bien vamos a trabajar juntos veamos
el inciso a dice esteban empacó 42
barras de dulce en su mochila el regalo
siete de ellas a sus amigos cuántas
barras de dulce le quedan a esteban
bueno en este escenario no estamos
dividiendo en este escenario empezamos
con 42 barras de dulce y quitamos siete
de ellas es decir la expresión adecuada
para este inciso sería 42 menos 7 que no
es 42 entre 7 así que eliminaré esta
opción bien el inciso b
julia tiene 7 bolsas de caramelos cada
bolsa tiene 42 caramelos cuántos
caramelos en total tiene julián bueno
por cada bolsa de caramelos ella tiene
42 de ellos por lo tanto esto será 7 por
42 / 7 así que también eliminaré esta
opción inciso se les lee corre en una
semana 42 minutos en total
si ella corre la misma cantidad de
minutos cada día cuántos minutos corre
el de si en un solo día bueno aquí nos
dicen que ella corre 42 minutos en total
cada semana y también que ella corre la
misma cantidad de minutos cada día la
semana tiene 7 días así que si queremos
encontrar la cantidad de minutos que ya
corre por día habrá que dividir los 42
minutos totales entre los 7 días de la
semana esta expresión nos ayuda a
encontrar cuántos minutos corre leslie
cada día así que este es el problema que
se resuelve dividiendo 42 entre 7 muy
bien hagamos otro ejemplo
aquí nos dicen miguel tiene 21 figuras
de acción él pone tres figuras de acción
en cada caja que representa la expresión
21 entre 3 pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta bueno esta es la
situación donde empezamos con 21 y
estamos dividiendo en grupos de 3
entonces estos son grupos de tres y esto
lo que nos dice es cuántos grupos
necesitamos entonces si nosotros
dividimos 21 en grupos de 321 en grupos
de 3 esto se da igual a un cierto número
tal vez algunos de ustedes ya sepan que
el número es pero esto lo que representa
es cuántos grupos hay cuántos grupos
y aquí una caja representa un grupo
entonces esto representa el número de
cajas el número de figuras de acción en
cada caja ya nos lo dicen son tres
figuras de acción por caja y eso se
representa solamente con un 3 y el
número total de figuras de acción
también nos lo dan él tiene 21 figuras
de acción el número de cajas es el
número total dividido entre la cantidad
que pondrá en cada caja bien hagamos uno
más alejandro martí y víctor dividen una
caja con 12 galletas en partes iguales
qué expresión nos ayuda a encontrar la
cantidad de galletas que cada uno de los
amigos recibe elige una respuesta bien
pausa el vídeo y ver si puede resolverlo
bien vamos a dividir 12 galletas
entonces comenzamos con 12 y vamos a
dividirlo en cuántas personas vamos a
dividirlo
bueno vamos a dividirlo entre una
persona alejandro dos personas
marta tres personas víctor por lo tanto
vamos a dividir entre tres grupos
iguales y aunque ya sabes cuánto es esto
no necesitamos resolverlo si nos
preguntan cuántas galletas recibe cada
persona
bueno será 12 dividido entre 3 que es el
inciso a 3 entre 12 no tiene sentido en
este contexto no tienen 3 galletas y no
lo estás dividiendo entre 12 personas y
el inciso se tampoco es correcto porque
no estás dividiendo 12 galletas entre
dos personas las estás dividiendo entre
3 personas